pour le lead à elisa ses préparations de
commandes dans leur entreprise cassis et
malice elles ont dû mettre de côté leur
activité de traiteur et ont décidé de
livrer des repas à domicile pour les
particuliers et le personnel soignant
on avait envie de faire quelque chose
pour les soignants qui se mobilisent en
ce moment et du coup on a lancé une
canette sur le site internet qui
permettait à la base de vendre les repas
pour proposer aux personnes qu'ils
souhaitent d'offrir un repas hauteur de
8 euros pour des soignants donc en gros
au off la matière première une matière
première de qualité nous on cuisine et
ensuite on va livrer différents
établissements aujourd'hui on va livrer
deux ehpad pour les livraisons les deux
gérantes ont dû s'adapter et appliquer
des gestes barrières sur le chemin elles
se rendent dans des commerces de
proximité pour récupérer quelques dons
avant de se diriger vers les pattes de
la mgen
nous on est effectivement à l'arrêt mais
il y en a qui se bat tous les jours pour
essayer de ba de soigner au mieux les
personnes touchées par locaux vides ou
les personnes qui sont un peu plus
faibles et du coup on a essayé bas de
rejoindre des circuits qui était déjà
mis en place
on n'a pas de par la distance c'est un
peu compliqué donc on a mis ça en place
au menu ce midi pour l'équipe soignante
linguini truite brocoli et asperges du
fait maison qui ravissent est cadre de
santé
ce qui me touche c'est de voir qu'il ya
beaucoup d'élan de solidarité de la part
de beaucoup de d'entreprise qui
finalement peuvent être en difficulté
financière mais qui malgré tout
continuent à faire des dons 2 et des
dons via des offres de repas un élan de
solidarité que le personnel soignant
espère voir se prolonger
notamment pour le matériel médical comme
les masques élégant qui pourraient venir
à manquer